okay what does ufos have to do with
magic and all of these things and why
are we even talking about this these
jinn are coming in the
disguise that suits the people of that
land they will show up in the form that
those people will
readily accept and believe now they
start showing up as aliens before
they would show up as an elf or the
spirit of uh
of mary if it's a christian country
right you don't hear in america about
a bunch of hindu statues drinking milk
you hear about ufos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the prophet saws said if the man if
mankind did not sin
allah would destroy us all all of
mankind and replace us with another
civilization that does sin just so we
can repent
and learn the value of allah's mercy
subhanallah
[Music]
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya
we're back with the same people again we
are missing
the uh king of intimacy
listen i said is the last thing wrong if
that's his last thing i don't know
that's not even his last name bro all
right bro it is what it is
hey listen listen we love the brother
he's just not here
he's been uh extremely busy but
inshallah
uh we'll catch him in another ep but for
today's ep
we are continuing from the first one
uh a little bit more structure than the
first video but
still again guys don't expect too much
structure
this is a conversation nonetheless so
you guys know how conversations roll
and with that being said
i will let you guys take it off from
where we left off
in the first ep so inshallah i was
in the last episode i talked about
project blue book and what the results
of project blue book were
before i do that my brother wanted to
mention a little bit about what
the quran says about magic so that
people that are listening can have a bit
of a background control
okay so i think um what i wanted to look
at was a couple heirs in surah baqarah
um many of them are the syrians so the
scholars of the seer
of the exegesis is an explanation of
quran so the scholars who explain it
look at these ayahs and say this is
perhaps where magic originated from
um and it explains in these two ayahs so
the quran says in ayah 101 absorb
which is the second chapter
came to them to confirm what was already
given to them
so they accepted that muhammad said it
was true at the time muhammad some of
the jews
but they still disbelieved so then they
threw the book of
the book that they had been given the
scripture of allah the torah
behind their backs as if they did not
know and then the next ayah and it's
long in arabic i'll just do the
englishes
so they followed instead what the devils
had recited um to solemn
who is a prophet or solomon as as is
known in the biblical narrative or
the in the the yeah in the biblical
narrative
um and then the ayah says it was not a
man who disbelieved um
so what does this mean it means that
doing magic one is disbelief is kapha so
it's a major major sin
and the jinns were the ones who used to
teach it
so they the devils used to teach magic
in
um the same as that which was revealed
to the two angels
in babel and babel or babylon
is an ancient city and it's said to be
where
magic originated from so if you look at
different strands of magic you look at
even horoscopes
if you look at where the origin is it
says babylon which is quite interesting
um and that's in the secular science in
islam we also know
a lot of magic originated from here so
these two angels used to teach people
but they didn't use to teach them unless
they used to say um we are a fitness
fellow so we are trial don't disbelieve
so it's a clear warning so the idea was
magic is a test for people
it offers some sort of power some sort
of gain that they may be able to get
however it's a it's a major disease it's
a trial
don't ever touch it stay away if you do
so you're leaving the fold
of um islam whether that be islam at the
time of different prophets of course
but it still applies to this day and yet
they learn
that which causes separation between a
man and his wife they do not harm anyone
through it except by the permission of
allah so
in in christianity this is this false
dichotomy of
the devil and and god and magic and
good and light this idea that almost the
devil can
or shaitaan can almost harm a law they
are on equal footing and islam we know
it's that's the complete
like is is so far from the truth because
when shaytan was being thrown out of
um janna he said robbie he said my lord
so he was asking allah he was um in
another
another part of the quran he says
he said i can't remember the english
word but it's basically
let me live until the day they're
resurrected so
he shaitaan is alive he's been alive
from the time of adam and eve before all
the way till now and he will be alive
all the way until the day of judgment so
he's been given that
allah accepted that but the point is he
said allah rabbi he said
yo my lord so he recognized allah as his
lord
which shows you there's no way there's
equal footing in fact
even shaitaan knows that allah is the
lord of everything and he has no power
so magic can't harm anyone unless allah
wants it that's a key lesson
um and finally but the children of
israel certainly knew
that whoever purchased their i.e magic
would not have it in the hereafter any
share
and wretched is that for which they sold
themselves if only they knew
so they're purchasing magic at the cost
of
janna so the whole discussion that we're
having now is based on this so
this ancient thing called magic all this
branches
it all comes back to this one tree and
it was sent as a test for mankind so
anytime you speak about it all the power
that people say you know you'll have
this and you'll learn this and you'll
have this insight
you'll gain this power it's nothing man
it's it's just a test from online you're
just selling it even if you do gain
something in this life
you're not gonna you're not gonna see
any share of the hero after but yeah i
just wanted to
open this episode with that that hey
because i think it's important
so i do want to just give uh one
small correction with that he asked
allah to
uh basically for immortality until
judgement day
allah did not grant him uh
immortality till judgment day he said
he said i'll grant you um
i'll grant this extra time but only to a
certain point
so he is going to die before judgment
day but probably
like when exactly or how soon before
judgmental only allah knows but
um not all the way till judgement day no
one has that none of the created
uh beings that are going to have the
allah
makes that clear that when the horn is
blown
or when the trumpet is blown by the
angel uh that all
all living things will die everything
will die except allah
should have mentioned he yeah like he's
not exempt from that yeah yeah
it's probably confusing so um
with that with that being said i think i
want to take it now to
the whole ufo thing because a lot of
people are okay what does ufos have to
do with
uh magic and all of these things and why
are we even talking about this is
some type of crazy conspiracy theory and
this is ridiculous and silly
so in the 1950s was
when the us government uh started to
look seriously into ufos you had a lot
of
airship sightings and a lot of strange
type of alien
sightings we have the whole the gray man
with the big head and the black eyes and
the
weird looking long fingers so america
started a project blue book to look into
these sightings they looked into
many of these sightings and the
i believe they closed it in the 1960s
and
what happened was with this think tank
that they hired to start project blue
book
it closed down and what they did was
they said oh all of this is just
natural phenomenon that the pilots are
mistaking it for
and obviously this wasn't a convincing
answer because they continued to do
other projects and to look into this
and now finally in 2020
they have admitted that yes there are
unidentified aerial phenomena we have
no idea what they are and for the
longest time the
the u.s air force and the navy had three
criterion first for ufo sightings and
how they categorized it you had
eyewitness only then you had radar only
and then you had eyewitness and radar
which was considered to be the strongest
type
of uh witness report where you had the
pilot flying
he catches something on the radar and he
sees the ufo
and you had thousands and thousands of
these you have so many of these
and one really big one that i would ask
people to look up
is the 1976 tehran ufo incident and
during this time you had uh tension
between
iran and america and what happened was
they intercepted or they saw a very uh
a very fast moving object in the sky the
iranians did
they tried to intercept it they sent
some fighter pilots after it
and this thing whatever it was flew
around the planes very quickly
it shut off their engines uh so the
people couldn't fly so the pilots
couldn't fly correctly
and they were not able to open fire on
it they were not able to catch it
right and people and this is actually a
well-documented report and of course
analysis that people give oh it's not
really a loofah it's just some
odd light or something that was unusual
um
and it just so happened that at the same
time there there they had an equipment
failure so that's kind of how
they tried to explain it away and we
know that's that's very unlikely
right that would be very unlikely but
people looked at this
and said three things one thing that
this is most likely to be some type of
secret u.s technology
that's most likely what it is that
perhaps there's some secret branch of
the government or
military that is developing this
technology because
the design of the flying saucer was
first seen during uh hitler's time
the nazis were experimenting with that
so they're like okay this might be some
some very high some very advanced
technology that only the us military has
because only the us military is capable
of such advanced technology
and other people in the us military
don't know about it the other theory
was that this is extraterrestrial right
it's coming from another planet
and then you had a third theory based on
all of the sightings
which was called ultra-terrestrial
hypothesis
so you had cnes which was the french
space agency
also has an ongoing ufo research group
the difference with
france however is because france is a
smaller country ufo occurrences and
sightings happen to a lot of high
uh to a lot of people in high levels of
government so they took the ufo
uh incidents much more seriously
right now you have one of the main
people who's also a respected scientist
worked with nasa
works in the cnes uh is a computer
scientist he's even in certain ted talks
as well so he's not some type of
crackpot
a theorist he's actually considered to
be uh respected in
the normal scientific community and
that's jake's valet
and he is a serious ufologist he was the
one who came up with the
ultra-terrestrial hypothesis which was
basically that this could not be
explained by extraterrestrials coming
from outside of the planet
right because just the vast number of
sightings
and the way that the sightings are are
operating
it shows that there's something against
and he brings some evidences of that and
you have other authors too who subscribe
to the series such as john keel
who wrote the book um
operation trojan horse and
in these books what they're talking
about basically is that
certain things that these aliens want
such as for example you have
abduction reports of people having sex
with the aliens or aliens taking samples
of the
of human skin to get their dna or their
biologists
if this is really an advanced
civilization
from another uh from another uh planet
these are very inefficient ways to get
dna to get biological samples to get
sperm they could easily
uh get what they need from a sperm bank
and no one would know what the
technology they have if that was
actually the technology that they had
if they actually had this type of
technology of transporting from place to
place so quickly
abducting people beaming them up into
the air then they don't need to do these
things to get what they're trying to get
that was one theory also the vast number
of theories means that
if we look at these thousands and
thousands of theories
not theory sorry sightings and the fact
that each little aircraft looks
different
then they're thinking that there's some
planet
far away where they're just sending
thousands and thousands of random
aircraft and somehow we don't we haven't
spotted them
so they're like this is also very
far-fetched
he also had an incident where someone
had an abduction report
and he said that he saw a star map right
this was one of the big
one of the bigger ufo abduction cases
that
got and gained media attention so i
think it was the woman said that she saw
a star map
right and someone tried to map out the
star map
and again jakesville and these authors
authors that looked deeper into these
like first of all the star map doesn't
make sense because it's from the point
of view of a human being looking at it
from earth
so there's clearly some type of
deception it's not a star map that
someone from another planet is using
because you can't use this type of star
map
and star map is again from the point of
view of someone from earth looking at
the map so that points more into the
direction that these
are what they call ultra terrestrials
they live on earth but we can't see them
and even though they're not muslim and
they may not have studied gin or maybe
they have
they came very close to a theory that
said that they must be made out of some
type of energy
or this must be some type of energy
based intelligence
you had uh the ufo
would transform into a cloud of smoke
you had the ufo would break down into
other little machines
you would have two people getting
abducted by the same ufo
but they both experienced something
totally different you had people see a
ufo that looks circular well then when
they take a picture and the picture
comes out
the ufo is shaped like a star so again
their eyes don't didn't register what
they actually saw or the ufo
shifted its uh shape right before
the picture was taken right so you have
all of these things and then you have
many different people that had ufo that
went through ufo sighting said you know
i feel like
these ufos were living creatures they
weren't machines the way that they acted
was as if it was a living being
that had intelligence and knew what it
was doing so
jakesville and these other people these
other researchers in ufo
just noted this and they said look the
extraterrestrial hypothesis might sound
nice because it fits with our atheist
modern
modernist concept of science fiction but
if we look at the evidence
there's something deeper going on so he
had a groundbreaking book that he
published in
early 1960s i believe in 1970s what's
called passport to morgonium
and he goes over about a thousand close
encounters and documents the
similarities across cultures and across
time to come to a conclusion on this and
his belief was that ufo sightings
ghost sightings angel sightings
demon sightings are all part of the
exact same phenomenon
that manifests itself differently
according to time and place
so i'm going to pause real quick because
i don't have any questions before i keep
going
keep going all right so he had another
book where he called
messengers of deception he wrote a book
called messengers of deception
and in that book so passport to mongonia
was looking at close encounters
and abduction reports right messengers
of deception was looking at alien
contact t reports
so people that were saying that we were
contacted by aliens and we have a
message from them
right so he shows his distrust of these
entities by examining the cults that
worship them and the people that said
that they were contacted by aliens
so he notes the fact that the contact
he's become fanatics
that believe in factually incorrect
information that is easily proven false
something like for example the aliens
come to a group and they say oh the
world is going to end on this day and
nothing happens the world does not end
on this day
and instead of the people saying you
know maybe these entities lie to us or
maybe these entities don't exist
they say no defenses exist we still
believe in them 100
and they come up with some random which
is like oh they were just testing our
faith or we misunderstood the day or
whatever excuse that they give for these
aliens
so the fact this context isn't from
fanatics uh the entities actually seem
to care very little
for their chosen mediums or context and
the word medium here is used
purposefully
john keel an operation trojan horse uh
he actually gives
a a parallel between the medium
says that he contacts spirits of the
dead and these contactees who say that
they cannot
contact aliens and he said that the way
that it works is exactly the same
you have the spirit saying that it's
this dead body and the medium
is listening to it and says he tells the
family your toast whoever is listening
okay this is spirit so and so he's from
the dead he's giving us information
so what does that entity do it gives
some specific information
that tries to prove to that person that
they are indeed a spirit from the dead
and then everyone believes the medium
and they believe that oh he's talking to
spirits of the dead
so the same thing with the contactees
they are given some type of information
to for the person to believe that oh it
must be an alien from outer space and
this must be the instructions
that they are given so as i said before
that fact was explored in the book
operation children horse
and the cults and the contactees they
said
they share the same features and
characteristics if i could
share screen real quick can you give me
the ability to share a screen i do want
to show one thing
yeah for sure now let me know when i can
no you could do it now no you're you're
you're hostile you could do all right
cool cool
so you see this this was in this is an
operation trojan horse
so this is the dotted lines represent
poultry i don't know how to pronounce
this or portuguese culture
older guys thank
so these basically ghost sightings and
supernatural sightings
and the heavy line the the thick black
line represents ufo reports
so you see as we have an increase in ufo
reports we have basically
superimposed same amount for alien
report
for for ghost sightings so they're
saying look why is it that when there's
more
ufo sighting there's also more alien
sightings
and they basically this is one and the
same thing because the pattern
is basically the same i'll stop sharing
screen now
the pattern is basically the same
you have an alien comes down in either
in a ufo
or the person is beamed up as with the
dmt experience they feel like they're
shot out of their body
and then the aliens have a message to
give them
and inshallah when we go over the dmt uh
studies we'll see that uh there was a
study and
inshallah brotherhood will go over that
study where
someone went through thousands of
people's experiences and he did a survey
of them and he
and he broke down all of the messages
that the dmt entities gave
to those people and you'll also see that
those messages
are very similar to the aliens messages
and follow the same pattern
so you have um they're giving they're
giving a message
uh usually it's something about telling
the human being will evolve to a higher
level of consciousness
uh which is basically the same thing as
saying that you're gonna be a god and
you have the same thing with the dmt
or yoga as well or any of these new age
philosophies wherein
oh you're going to obliterate yourself
and you're going to become one with god
or the alien version of that is
you're going to evolve from matter to
become an energy human being you're
going to leave behind your physical
carbon body or whatever some some random
thing that
it's not gonna happen but it makes the
person feel like they've been chosen
right
uh another thing was making a contract
or a deal or an exchange of gifts for
the alien would give something or would
ask a human being for something very
random like water or a piece of food
that they might not even use and then
the alien gives them something in return
you have sexual contact where either
it's forced or the aliens expect okay
look you're gonna have sex with this
alien woman and that happens a lot in
the abductee reports
and this is also what makes authors like
uh
jakes valet and john keel and all these
other authors say look this is the same
thing as people when they got kidnapped
by fairies or kidnapped by elves
it was pretty much the exact same thing
the exact same
pattern the form or the outer appearance
was different
in alien versus mouth but it was
actually very similar whether it was uh
whatever or a spirit of the dead right
whatever that person thought it was the
pattern was the same
right uh sometimes even in religious
sightings you will have someone saying
oh i saw the spirit of
mary and it's not mary because
the mary's and each time look very
different from each other so if someone
sees
mary in south america versus someone
sees mariaris and i'm in another country
but again the message is the same i want
you to build something for me here
i will give you this thing and we'll
have an exchange of gifts
uh possession or spiritual attack this
is a big one
because how is it that an alien
abduction report makes it feel that way
but you have people that say
so for example you have a medium or a
ghost or
entity talking to someone and what does
the person do they write down what the
alien is saying or they speak
the alien is speaking through them
generally speaking when we think of
stuff like that we think of ghosts we
think of
demons we think of jin but no this also
happens with
aliens people say oh the alien is
speaking through me or they're speaking
through me
so how is it if it's from another planet
that they can do that
well that's very much closer to what we
see as
uh spiritual attacks right uh bright
lights
feeling of parallel paralysis telepathic
communication when i say telepathic
communication i don't mean they can
start
doing telepathy with human beings i mean
that telepathic communication in the
sense that
they think that they're telepathically
communicating with the alien so you have
the same thing when people are doing dmt
or ace of projection
telepathic communication with whatever
the entity is if they think they saw a
god or a goddess if they think they saw
a
spirit of the dead if they think they
saw elf whatever they thought they saw
it followed the same thing uh the beings
lie about their nature and this was
another
really really big one for uh people who
are in intelligence agencies looking at
these alien
abduction reports they're like yo these
creatures can be trusted
one time they say they're from mars
another time they say they're from some
random solar system from another planet
from another galaxy another time they
say oh they're actually planets behind
the sun by the way
we're from those planets behind the sun
so
every time there's a ufo abduction
report it's always the aliens always
change up their story about where they
come from and what planet they're from
right so they're like okay either
there's thousands of
these and there's thousands of other
aliens from thousands of other planets
sending
a ufo spacecraft to us or it's something
here on earth
and that's that's the conclusion that
many of these researchers came to when
they look at the evidence
uh and here's another one giving some
hidden intro such as where a lost item
is found or an intimate detail of the
person that nobody else knows about
this is again a case of jin attack a lot
of people know
who are who have had experiences with
jinn know that this is one of
the things that magicians do to try and
trick the person to gain their trust
you have the aliens do the same thing
they say oh we know this about your life
or we know this about where your lost
object is
uh and that happens in ghost reports in
alien sightings
in uh fairies whatever it is that the
spirit or
being says that it is if it says it's
the spirit or not
it's the same exact pattern so when
these authors know
all of these things they say that there
is no way
that this is from outer space this is
all part of the same
phenomenon and inshallah if
you guys can edit this in the cover of
passport to magonia is basically an
alien holding up different masks
do you want to do you want to just show
that with a screen share yeah yeah
sure uh let me see if i have it yeah go
for it bro sure so
and i recommend people to look at these
books because again
these are these are these are
non-muslims and
some of them don't even believe in
religions and they're coming they're
coming to these conclusions all on their
own
so um let me see
if i can show you guys this real quick
sorry my computer yeah no worries bro if
not we'll just tell our editor to put it
in
no i got i got you it's to show up right
now it's literally the first thing that
you see
so i'll share a screen once more um
i'm trying to break the flow here
so if i zoom in the the cover says it
all
and throughout the book he's trying to
prove this
that they're all one and the same right
so anyways moving on let's look at the
the strange messages that they give
right so
if we look at these messages that the
creatures give
love is the answer to everything people
should eliminate culture and money
uh you are chosen and you are special
you will evolve to a higher level
or sometimes alien even says that they
are messengers of god or that they
should be worshipped
right uh people have this experience on
dmt
when they meet dmt entities people also
have this experience
with uh with yoga and with new age
practices and
meditative practices where they say that
they've been obliterated and
uh there is no moral right or wrong
right love is the answer to everything
is the same thing as saying there's not
no morals there's no right or there's
wrong
there's no right or wrong uh the yoga
and the hindu gurus will also say that
you know everything is an illusion
it's all these paths all lead to the
same thing so there's no real divine law
it's just whatever you
feel is right uh people should eliminate
just
sorry bro i don't want to cut you off um
or interrupt but just uh i think it's
interesting to jump in you mentioned
like hinduism and stuff
and well speaking earlier um like
if you look at the actual depictions of
these hindu entities
and then you look at depictions of what
people say aliens or even like
psychedelic dmt entities and stuff like
that look like
it's like a mirror images with many
heads and all these arms and
in all these different cultures wherever
they seem to manifest they're always
like these common traits so
they always have like these weird facial
features or yeah it's just
the big the big dark eyes and so forth
um i want to hop on on what you're
saying because what these authors are
noting they're like why
now are they coming as aliens and they
note that
uh in the book messengers of deception
right which the book says at all how
these authors feel about these aliens so
they're a little less fanatic about the
whole aliens thing and they want to look
at this
from a rational point of view they
noticed that in the 1950s and in the
1940s
as society started as western society
started moving towards
um as western society started moving
more towards atheism towards materialism
then what do these jinns show up as now
they start showing up as aliens and and
the big brained green or gray skinned
figure
with no hair whereas before they would
show up as
an elf or they'd show up as the spirit
of uh
of mary it's a christian country right
so whatever that country is
or whatever that area is they will show
up in the form that those people will
readily accept and believe so that's why
he calls them messengers of deception
right so now we have aliens uh
one of the other messages when we look
at i want to break down each message
people should eliminate culture and
money
what does that mean it's the same thing
as this utopian vision or communism
where
no one owns anything everything is owned
by
all of us there's no family so yeah it
might seem nice on the surface but it's
actually very evil
no individual choice no family no people
that i love
or love is the answer to everything and
that's the same thing that the
pedophiles say right
love knows no borders many people use
something that sounds
good on the outside but when we look
deeper into it
it's very counter to a productive
society aliens telling people you are
chosen or you are
uh and again this is reading superiority
and racism oh you are the chosen one
same thing with these uh yoga masters
you know people go bow down to their
feet and kiss their feet
because why because he's chosen special
he's reached enlightenment i'm just i'm
just a nobody trying to reach
enlightenment with him
you will evolve to a higher level uh
this is all again a cult-like belief
people saying that they believe in god
or the aliens just straight up saying
you worship them and we see this in the
same thing with the hindu gods
so depending on what the um
place where the time is the entity will
come
or the jinn let's not call them entities
anymore that's what they call let's call
them just
for what it is the jinn will come in a
certain form to trick the person into
believing into
that to believing that person right and
when when we realize that the pattern is
the exact same pattern across
time and across place then we know that
this is the same thing
right it's the same thing as detective
work right if we see a murder i don't
have to see the murder but if i see a
murderer and that murder looks the exact
same with all these other murders then
the detective's gonna be like yo this is
probably the same person
or it's a poppy cat killer that's
copying another killer
but usually they'll say this is the same
person or it's the same robber he left
his trademark here in the house the way
he robbed it
so by looking at all of these cases when
we notice that there's a pattern then we
notice okay this is the same
entities and the same beings now how
these beings are accessed that's
different so sometimes the ufo will come
to the person
or the ghost will come to the person in
there and while they're awake
sometimes the person takes drugs
sometimes the person does
meditation sometimes the person does
whatever practice
that they do but the end result is the
same to make contact or to facilitate
contact
uh with these beings so in america it's
going to be ufos and ufo sightings
right because again people like oh i
don't believe in religion i don't
believe in dogma
so if an alien comes or if a jinn comes
in the form of a religious figure that
person's not going to listen
no it's just a dream but if the alien
the gin comes in the form of an alien
and that person's already materialistic
atheists and their views no oh my god
aliens came to me from another planet
and they told me this and you told me
that so then they're going to believe
so i do want to show you guys something
in india for example you're not going to
get real ufo sightings
you're going to get something else and i
will show you guys just how deep
this gin trickery goes and again
everything that i'm showing you guys
is not underground conspiracy theories
these are all respectable scientists
you have if you just look just a couple
days ago on 60 minutes you had the
navy pilot uh air force pilot come out
saying yes
um ufo sightings are real we don't know
what you are yet
and uh but yeah it's official now
pentagon is coming
you've got elon a couple like literally
just before we
start filming it was like tweeting out
what do you say again talking about
technology and advanced technology
yeah yeah i'll say right now he
had tweeted any sufficiently advanced
magic
is indistinguishable from technology
and i want to break down that later but
first i want to show you guys this video
because i think that this video will
launch us into all of these other topics
such as emt and yoga and so forth
so i'm going to share screen
uh one more time hopefully like the
audio and everything works yeah it
should work because i optimized it for
video clip and audio so this is on bbc
news and this happened about five six
years ago
and uh it was a really big deal but it
didn't catch fire in in the western
world like no one really
watched this or cared about this right
so uh this happened more than once by
the way but this was in september 1995.
so let's take a look at this
[Music]
crowds mobbed temples all over india to
see ganesh the elephant
god credited with bringing prosperity
drinking milk
as people throughout the nation declared
it a miracle others cashed in
charging five times the normal price for
milk
[Music]
so guys i don't want to waste
everybody's time
but ultimately ultimately what happens
if you go online i i just wanted to show
you that bbc
clip and they didn't show it that
accurately but
you can actually look it up that they
put spoons of milk
to the statue and the milk would start
disappearing
and this happened all across india
and i think i read in some ways that
even even hindu statues outside of india
and other countries
that thing happened to them too so again
we know that the jinn
allah tells us can do certain things
right
uh they can move certain objects they
can mess with people in certain ways
but we can make our prayers to protect
us from those type of supernatural
activities
but you don't hear in america about
you know um a bunch of hindu statues
drinking milk
you hear about ufos so again these gin
are coming in
the disguise that suits the people of
that land
to try and trick them into uh believing
in whatever false religion if we know
just as how brother khalid was saying
that um
the purpose of shape on is to lead
mankind astray from the truth
so what better way to do that than by by
relying on human beings
naive foolishness showing them a bunch
of pseudo miracles and then
all of a sudden you have a fanatic oh
aliens exist oh look my hindu statue is
drinking milk
uh clearly that hindu statue is real and
it goes on from there you know so
i got like two reflections yeah i got
like two reflections just
off the back of that like the first one
being they're saying it's a miracle but
of course we know in islam there's like
three types of
supernatural events one is an actual
miracle from allah which came with the
prophets and
whether that be jesus or moses all of
these prophets
they had like real miracles and then
there's some things like karamat
the karma like the the glad tidings
these blessings that allah
gives some of his his um believers you
know in times of hardship so if they're
on the battlefield
they'll see some some uh they're like
miraculous things almost impossible
things but those are
some things that he blesses people and
then there's the third type which is
this type that we're dealing with now
which is like these satanic
quote-unquote miracles but they're not
real
miracles from god they're just tricks
and there's trickery and all of these
like
dark hearts and this the dark hearts
that all of this kind of fits on the
and the second thing that i was thinking
about was that they have to disguise
themselves right they have to put on
these different masks to fit
you know the the cultures that they go
into the times that they're going to
whereas what's so beautiful about islam
and one's one thing that strikes me to
islam is
it's the same universal message that
just connects with everyone because it
goes to the fedra so
everyone has the everyone every single
human being regardless of time and place
has the
the internal um that internal message
already within them
from the moment their soul was created
so islam just goes and
reaches into that so it doesn't have to
disguise itself it's just there
so it's in the openness it's clear the
message is cleared
it doesn't have to can conceal itself
and trick people which is
yeah it's the complete opposite complete
opposite yes
yeah i think that's a good point to
bring up is that when we look at all of
the prophets they're saying the same
thing there's one god worship this one
god
but when we look at the um as
as as the as the book written by jake's
ballet says
messengers of deception which is a
really good term for it
they're always changing their message
they're always trying to change
their form to shoot the people that are
listening but the point is that they
just want to get them off of the truth
and i think that goes back to what i was
saying in episode one where muslims saw
the solar eclipse and prophet muhammad
look this solar eclipse is not something
that happens because someone died
it's just something from allah and
that's it
so he if he was a false prophet he could
have ate off of that superstition
and said yes it is because so-and-so
died and you know
but he proves that he's not a prophet by
he prove he proves that he is a prophet
a non-profit would have done the
opposite
he would have tried to use this to uh to
trick the people
right but prophet muhammed because he is
a prophet saying no this is not
something that happens because someone
died he's trying to move people away
from superstitious beliefs
and this has always been what the
prophets have tried to do
to get people away from superstitious
beliefs inshallah so
with that being said we have on our
youtube channel
uh entire serial entire video on on the
dmt thing
where we bring in uh different sources
i share my screen a lot more i don't
want to do it here cause it's gonna take
way too long to share different screens
and share different pictures
but it is official now pentagon has
admitted to the whole ufo
phenomenon and this is just recently so
yeah that's basically that's basically
where we're at now and um
ufos is just another manifestation of
this whole
new age culture well i was going to say
do you guys want to start another
episode and
go into the dmt now yeah sure i'm sure i
i i probably have to get going so i
might have to do this episode another
time
perfect all right
everyone if you have a few minutes and
it's not going to take too long we could
just continue and add the dmt portion
here
but if you feel like it should be its
own episode then definitely
it probably should be its own episode
because at this point brother falil is
going to go start talking and he's going
to go into
the john hopkins dmt study where they go
over thousands of people that did dmt
so uh and and he's going to go over the
messages the breakdown what people
saw so yeah that's that's a whole other
a whole other portion inshallah then
yeah we should all give some our final
thoughts
for this episode i know you got into
your mind
um yeah i do have a lot of questions but
i feel
like these questions are heavily tied in
with the antique
yeah it's definitely questions in
regards to what we've spoken about
now here about the entities about
the gin and how they're presenting
themselves in
different ways and whatever suits the
the people that they are presenting
themselves to
but again these questions are heavily
tied in with dmt
so it's like if i ask them it's only
just going to lead into the dmt
thing so i'm best to say before the dmt
video
ask them anyway if we get to them you
get to them if not you might forget them
so
we'll just be able to refer to them next
time anyway so
yeah inshaallah so
um one thing
that i'm thinking of here is uh
so we have the gin presenting themselves
as different things to different people
correct yes um then we have people like
shamans and i guess
they'll call themselves uh psychics
like gurus and stuff like that
was like okay they some of them may not
even be taking
substances to increase dmt
but they are still seeing these things
these different entities
and um they might place different labels
on them and stuff like that
but then and i honestly like i'm losing
my train of thought here
and this is a really good question so if
i completely forget this
we'll have to come back but um
[Music]
yeah we're gonna have to come back bro
no problem i just
mentioned this one thing like you
mentioned something interesting how they
still see these entities even though
they don't taking these
drugs and stuff one study that i came
across
not that long ago i think i shared it
with you ahmed uh about from like
harvard was about witchcraft and stuff
where they used to rub like plants on
their eyes and um
they they started seeing entities like
that and then i read something in
um or heard something else somewhere
about the ten moods so
the jews obviously they have the torah
but they don't follow that the same
like in the same way we follow the quran
so they have
without going to in too much detail they
can just like take two minutes
um they were raided and invaded
and conquered by the babylonians which
is again kind of linked to what we were
speaking about earlier and
many of the rabbis um who started living
in
that environment where there was a lot
of magic it influenced their thought
and so a lot of jewish writing and
and one of the versions of the telemud
was written in um
it speaks and it has a lot of demonic
practices within it and one of them is
interesting was
it was like uh burning and cooking
something and then
grounding it into a powder and then
rubbing it in your eyes in order to see
the demons so
all of these things they have different
similarities so again
like it's all connected so everything
you're probably thinking about
that you think it relates to dmt but
it's linked to the ufos there's a reason
why because it's all interconnected so
yeah
i i see way well maybe where you're kind
of going with it
yeah i'm gonna be honest i completely
forgot the premises of the questions but
like i'm realizing or like what i wanted
to say with it what i want to like
you know transmit here is the fact that
engines
uh not only can they present themselves
as like
a certain thing but um it doesn't
necessarily even have to be
like a person or an entity or something
that it could be
even just a feeling you know like ahmed
was talking about how like
uh some guy would say oh i'm a muslim
because i felt
so and so it's like oh whoa is that why
you're muslim
because if if what you felt is what
really pulled you
into islam okay well what if the jinn
capitalized on that
and they're like ah okay um well let's
make him feel something over here okay
now he leaves ism he goes to
christianity
he's like oh let's capitalize even more
okay i'm not he feels something in the
new age
in the hinduism okay so he leaves
christian now he goes to hinduism
and then he just keeps following this
feeling until it leads him to a place of
no return
you know what i'm saying yeah and um
yeah in regards to the whole dmt thing
the way that i'm like
wrapping my head around it is um allah
subhanahu wa tala
gives us x amount
so that we experience said things or
x amount of things right but then when
we do all these other things
or let's say we do
one thing that causes this barrier of
you know
theoretically speaking it causes berry
to drop down a bit
right so now it is since we are a little
bit more susceptible
that means a gin can do something that
will
just affect us slightly more and just by
the gin doing something that affects us
slightly more it leads us down
this path where you're essentially
either one taking more dmt
you know externally or two you are
releasing
more dmt internally more than you are
supposed to be releasing
can and i speak that from the personal
experience when i
was uh going on this whole bout of
decalcifying the pioneer gland
to be able to experience more and i
started to experience things that uh
be honest i wish i didn't experience
so i think yes this is all tied in
together
this whole dmt thing and again i
i forgot my question but these are so
yeah i would love to see
just keep saying yeah that works
that happens to me a lot like whichever
direction you start going in like you
can talk about meditation for like
hours or you know the different
variations and then you have like stuff
like the wim hof method is that
connected is that connected to the
pineal gland yeah
at least like wherever you go with this
you can spend so
long because there's just so much uh to
think about so
sometimes when you try and ask questions
because it's happened this happens to me
to this day
um i just get lost because my train of
thought just
scrambles and i'm like well and again
that's exactly what happened bro
like i swear there's so much and it's
all tying in together that like i
started asking the question
and then it just kind of went away
from what i was asking so yeah my bad
forget
i'll talk again you know it happens
sometimes
i like to say out of the national energy
whenever i forget something
other than regime we're making some
[ __ ] same stuff for the law
and eventually you remember it you know
because
it's just uh and i remember i saw one of
the shield through that too and he
forgot something he said
until he remembered it you know
i got back to the stream of thought but
if there is no other questions
then we can we can wrap up inshaallah
and i'm sure that
the comment section is either going to
have haters
and those are from the people who have
not who have experienced this journey
who know what we're talking about on a
first-hand point of view but they
haven't experienced the dark side of it
yet
or if they have experienced the dark
side they're just explaining it away
no no that's not really what it is it's
just an integration
of your of your shadow into your wall of
law
it doesn't create any issues it just
brings out the real you
yeah yeah you know you know and they and
they like to cite carl young and say oh
these are just archetypes that you're
seeing in your mind and
you need to integrate your right side
with your shadow but carl young himself
was into magic he did astrology
he even wrote to freud because him and
freud uh he he wrote he wrote to
these different psychologists and he
said look when i have problems with my
patients
i jaw i drop their astrological charts
and i look at their zodiac sign and so
he was into astrology
he was into horoscopes he was into magic
he was into different branches of magic
so he was into magic so people say oh
you know this is not really
entities it's not really jin it's just
archetypes or whatever
uh and they cite carl young they don't
realize that carl jung himself is into
magic a lot of these
new age thinkers are magicians even if
they don't say that they are they are
magicians they just don't say that they
are because they want to
absorb and promote to as many people as
possible
that's also part of the deception that's
involved as well
i can see that yeah
and it goes to show like the uh
jahilia of people where it's like
the only they're only saying something
that they read or that they heard
and i get it you know we are also saying
something that we read
or that we heard and that we
internalized but
they're saying it from a premise of
no real research they haven't gone deep
to find the answers
of what they're talking about the truth
of what they're speaking about
and i feel like that oh man like that
that's dangerous i want to go off on
that for a second because
you might have someone say no i've been
doing dmt for
10 years it's like yeah but you haven't
really thought this through because
you just believe everything that these
entities are telling you you're not
really thinking about and i've
i've read like different people talking
about their experiences saying oh you
know
ancient egyptians live in hyperspace and
i've seen them with my two eyes and
i'm like okay but how do you know that
that's
actually what you're seeing you know
like like why are you seeing ancient
egyptians in hyperspace but
someone else is seeing clowns and uh or
whatever whatever it is that they're
they're observing what they're seeing so
my message to these people who are going
to hate on what they're watching right
now is to just
say how can you trust what you're seeing
why are you trusting what you're seeing
if someone says oh it's because the
feeling of the ecstasy well
my response to that is how many people
do you know or do we know
who've fallen in love with the wrong
type of girl you know
oh i fell in love with her and she's bad
she's the one man and like his life is
ruined because of it so
i'm not saying that love isn't real um
isn't a real feeling it's a very real
thing it's a very powerful feeling
that's a very good feeling
but you can't just make your decision
just off of that feeling you also have
to verify
you know and men like
a lot of them will say too that oh this
is just a belief pattern
you know like the belief pattern in
shamanism is the same as the belief
pattern
in islam but it's it's clearly not
because if you if you go back to the
starting point
and that's how you find the truth is you
you keep going back you keep
tracing it back to its origin like you
you look at shamanism
look when it first started and look for
how long it's been going on
and it's like okay um
it did not start in the beginning it did
not start from the very beginning
and if you look at it sound like it will
date back to the very beginning
it was adam peace be upon him
so it's like again like this is not
just a belief system like this is this
is the truth and if someone can't see
that or
they're choosing not to see it they're
choosing not to go
further in and research and find the
answers that they're looking for
yes probably wrong
there's so much more you feel like you
want to say right with this type of
topic because there's so
much into this but we can start
we'll try and save it for another for
another episode when we look at dmt
specifically
just to give a little breakdown john
hopkins did a study
on dmt uh and how many
you want to introduce the study just so
that you can give the people uh
a teaser into what's coming next yeah
just give them a taste bro
oh yeah i think off the top of my head
it was like 2560 one or two
participants who took part in this
massive survey
they looked at the main experience that
they had on dmt
they looked at the characteristics of
the dmt entities some of the messages
they received
so it was a super in-depth study and it
was specifically focused on the entity
so
that will you know you can see how that
will link into some of the
characteristics i had spoke about when
we were looking at um the different
books so yeah it was a really
comprehensive study on the entity
characteristics and then we'll be able
to flip that and say well look
islam encompasses both what we said
about ufos
these entities uh same thing with hindu
girls and all
all of these things man every single you
know
so-called paranormal activity uh
all comes back or comes back to this
umbrella of gin and their deception and
just finally i want to make a final note
i don't want people to think who maybe
haven't heard of jim before that they're
all bad
they're like human beings so some are
really good some are really bad
it's just like a spectrum um and some
muslims even some muslims
have this preconceived notion that all
genders are evil and horrible
no man some of them like really really
nice and
a really really good practicing people
some of them are scholars whatever like
they're
they're like mirrors of human beings
they just live in a different world that
we can't see so
we shouldn't make this idea that they're
all bad however they're shared in the
devils from them they are already bad
because not only are they bad but
they're unseen and they try to influence
your
humanity um and get in
all these secret societies and cults and
so yeah it's a whole
whole different world out there and
there's four i feel like some people
get it twisted or they say like oh well
there's good
gen then um why not communicate with
them but it's like dude we
do not know the unseen we you cannot
know
if what we are interacting with is
actually good or not we might feel that
it's good
but like ahmed was saying it starts with
good
it starts with something good and then
it'll lead you
to something bad and we were saying this
off the record bro
yeah yeah whereas like you take
you take a psychedelic or you do this
specific practice
and it gives you that good initial
feeling at folks but it's like
where it takes you bro
is not where you want to go and ah bro
i will plug in the whole side guru
experience here
do we have time should i do this we got
time bro let me say something real quick
just to add your point that
jin are not jenna told not to
communicate us with us and possesses in
the first place
so the fact that they're already doing
that they're possessing you they're
probably not a muslim good gender
bro so
yoga right yoga
when i was in in uh i want to say like
2017 2018
closing in 2019 um my fiancee and i had
split
so i was going through a period where i
was kind of lost
trying to find some meaning and uh do
something with my life
and the roommate that i had at the time
he's still a friend of mine
but at the time like very close and he's
a hindu
so he's very practicing of the hinduism
spiritual practice because it's not even
a religion if you look into it it's not
even a religion
uh and he started showing me more about
yoga and like the different forms of
yoga and i'm not gonna lie to you like
when i first started doing
these different forms of yoga i started
to experience these different
things and i was like oh wow that's
beautiful you know like
it didn't give me any lasting clarity
any lasting peace
any knowledge or anything like that it
was just feelings
but i started going deeper into it and
we found this
or he was onto this guru named uh
sad guru which anyone can look him up on
youtube
uh guys there he's popping in terms of
the
the the hinduism feel and and the crazy
thing is he doesn't even
classify himself as a hindu but he he's
clearly in
with the way that he practices and
things that he does the way he speaks
right so long story short
i started watching a whole bunch of
these guys videos and um
[Music]
i almost started taking things that he
says as
uh the truth and nothing but the truth
and he had this uh program that he was
running called inner engineering i think
he's still running it by the way
he was doing the actual convention in
dallas
texas and me and my boy ended up booking
a flight and going to this convention
and during this convention
let me just preface this by saying the
first day
he was just repeating stuff that he had
said on youtube
so the first day i was just like bro are
you serious like is this all we're gonna
hear just the same stuff that he's
saying on youtube
and um i was falling asleep everybody
was falling asleep then the second day
he said all right we're gonna show you
the practice now i'm like alright cool
finally like
you made us wait an entire day for this
like it better be good
and as he's showing us his practice
which is very
weird as well like there's all these
weird movements that you have to do
there's um there's these things called
the
anal locks uh yeah it's weird bro and
listen listen it gets it gets so weird
cause like
no and one of the things i'll i'll
slightly reveal a few of the details not
so much because i don't want anyone to
like be like oh let me look into this
like that
but um one of the things bro is like
you're sitting cross-legged
with an erect spine and you're um
you're looking up basically
hyperventilating
very short shallow and quick breaths
looking upwards like this
and then once you're done with that
you're taking one deep breath
basically tucking your chin going in
contracting your stomach and then
contracting your ass which they call an
anal lock
and um
[Music]
bro listen let me just say that uh in
the convention this one woman was having
trouble with the anal lock
and i stood up and grabbed the mic and i
was like oh listen when you're doing the
anal lock bro they cut me off real quick
they were like listen
you can't you can't tell the person how
to do it ain't no luck
but uh again it goes to show how weird
this
this practice was and that's just a
small little bit like it gets even
weirder than that
and when we did this practice in the
convention
he had said that um
[Music]
you're gonna experience different things
everyone's gonna experience something
different
um just go with it and if you hear
people when you're screaming and making
noises like it's all right just
disregard it i'm like
you you're saying to disregard people
screaming
like this all right this is a little sus
bro
this is a little sus and we started to
do the practice and
as we're going into it um
i start feeling like there's something
rising
in my body and i start feeling like my
body is becoming
lighter lighter and lighter and as i'm
feeling this
there's people all around in this
convention and keep in mind there's like
thousands of people
in this convention spot and all i
started here
is all these people screaming and it it
is
it was loud and it was the scariest
thing ever because like the only thing i
could
really uh link it to is
as if it was hell like the hellfire and
you're hearing the people screaming
because of torture or whatever it is and
like i remember hearing that and it's
like
this feeling of dread that was like
overcoming me of like no no no stop
like stop you're doing something wrong
like don't don't keep going don't keep
going
and like bro he was literally saying two
keep going
whenever you feel that point right there
so
it's kind of love bro it starts with
something simple
and then leads you to something that's
just it's not
it's not good it's the steps that
the devil makes you take it starts off
simple and innocent uh
as this saying goes the path of the hell
is paved with good intentions it starts
off as something not even sinful
right it's a good thing maybe you think
it's just
you know a nice bit of practice but if
you follow that path and you're not
careful and you don't tread
with safety that's it
and imagine imagine someone's like at
first if they first started
they're gonna be very skeptical so if
like if something
like what i had experienced at the inner
engineering happened when they first
started
they would be like oh no no no i'm not
this i'm this is not for me
right but like the fact that it starts
with something so little
is it it starts opening you up to it to
where you start believing
in it 100 and like you have faith in it
and then when it gets to that pivotal
point where it's like okay
you're gonna feel something where you
know internally is not right your moral
compass something inside of you is
directing you and telling you no like
don't keep going any further
and call that call it the color of allah
call that the guidance of allah i don't
know
i love welling but like it's there for a
reason
and at that point if someone is already
believing in it and
seeing it to be the truth it's very hard
for them to
step away yeah that's one that i gave
was put on inside and i recommend the
book
for people uh for everyone actually it's
called the exorcist tradition in islam
it's by bilal phillips
i have the book with me inshallah i can
probably show it to you guys in the next
episode
but uh the scholars mentioned things
like that these practices
jin can enter through the breath or
through the different type of breathing
extras so these exercises are a way for
jim to go inside of the body
so that's probably why he's saying oh
you're going to feel something just
ignore it because he knows that what's
going to happen is people are just going
to have ginger inside of them and people
are going to react to that in different
ways
so asphalt's not going to protect us
from all of that
uh there's so much more to talk about i
have to get going inshallah
but uh yeah we can pick this up on the
next episode
uh guys going forward we have an episode
coming up with
dmt we have another one on practices
like meditation astral projection all
that we're going to make one more
stuff like that so if you made it this
far anna which is the hashtag
hashtag entities
i thought you were going to one they
already know what it is
we have sisters watching this too so
let's let's be
that's fine bro that's fine they'll
understand it we're we're saying it in a
a very polite manner we're saying
a lot i would recommend from an islamic
etiquette point of view that our hashtag
i was just joking i had to do something
more more familiar
so if if you are if you've watched this
far
go ahead and hashtag um
hashtag entity but if you're a true jai
hill
you know what to put it's on y'all if
you put that it's not on us
we're not telling you guys and advising
you to put that
uh but yes
i'll see you guys in the next
if mankind did not sin allah would
destroy us all
all of mankind and replace us with
another civilization
that does sin just so we can repent and
learn the value of allah's mercy
subhanallah um
[Music]